ma dernière vidéo était consacrée à
schopenhauer philosophe dont on a vu que
son concept central c'était la volonté
la volonté du monde
7 cette force magmatique est infini qui
qui conditionne le monde de la réalité
sensible le monde de la représentation
aujourd'hui j'aurais souhaité parler
d'un auteur qui s'est lui-même défini
comme un disciple de schopenhauer
il est en quelque sorte le continuateur
de son oeuvre même s'il s'en écarte de
manière assez conséquente et ce
philosophe tout le monde le connaît de
nom c'est nietzsche la pensée de
nietzsche est difficile à saisir de
prime abord ne serait ce que par sa
forme
nietzsche écrivait sous forme
d'aphorismes la plupart du temps les
aphorismes ce sont des courts
paragraphes qui sont des sortes de
fulgurances philosophique et qui sont
assez difficiles à interpréter
c'est un penseur qui demande du temps
pour être vraiment digéré la pensée de
niche c'est une critique globale de la
culture occidentale
pour nietzsche
occidental est basée sur ce qu'il
appelle la morale du ressentiment et
cette morale du ressentiment ils
attribuent essentiellement au
christianisme
nietzsche combattez la pensée chrétienne
nietzsche combattez toute pensée qui a
été basée sur une distinction entre le
bien et le mal
en gros il combattait toutes les
idéologies qui prétendait dicter aux
hommes la manière de se comporter
nietzsche été pour la disqualification
de toutes les valeurs existantes et pour
la réhabilitation de nouvelles valeurs à
travers son concept du surhomme on va en
parler en profondeur alors j'ai fait
tout de suite une petite parenthèse sur
le nazisme
nietzsche est souvent accusée d'avoir
aspiré la pensée nazie
je vais donner mon point de vue
là-dessus qui n'est que mon point de vue
je le précise tout ça ce sont des
foutaises nietzsche à développer une
pensée une pensée philosophique une
pensée de l'humanité une vision
anthropologique et que des courants des
idéologies politiques
et puis s'appuyer sur eux sur sa pensée
c'est un fait mais s'appuyer sur une
pensée ne signifie pas que la pensée
était même fautive
on peut toujours utiliser une pensée
dans le sens de ses intérêts
d'ailleurs une pensée aussi riche que
que celle de niche peut facilement être
interprété dans le sens des intérêts
n'importe qui vous pouvez faire dire ce
que vous voulez à nietzsche comme vous
pouvez faire dire ce que vous voulez à
schopenhauer
il suffit de prélever quelques citations
qui vont dans le sens de votre
interprétation
c'est très facile donc je n'en dirai pas
plus la pensée de
j'ai basé sur une approche naturaliste
de la pensée c'est à dire une approche
biologique en fait de la pensée au
nietzsche toute philosophie vient du
corps ça veut dire qu'on pense comme on
est constituée physiologiquement la
pensée n'est pas indépendant du corps la
pensée émane du corps et notre
constitution biologique va déterminer la
manière dont on va penser se représenter
le monde
alors pour nice il ya plusieurs étapes
la physiologie détermine la morale et la
morale détermine l'intellect
c'est à dire les idées qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que pour
nietzsche un individu de constitution
faible aura une morale de faible et
parce qu'il a une morale de faibles il
aura des idées faible des idées deux
faibles pour need il y à des types de
pensée qui correspondent à des types
d'individus la philosophie de nietzsche
est donc basé sur une typologie une
classification des types d'hommes des
types de comportements qui correspondent
à des types de penser cette vision
très naturaliste de la pensée l'idée que
toute pensée émane d'un corps et que si
on comprend le corps d'où vient la
pensée et bien on comprend mieux la
pensée quand l'étudiant de manière
indépendante
cette méthode il va l'appliquer dans son
analyse
au lieu de partir d'une pensée pour la
critiquer sur son contenu
au lieu de faire sa niche lui va se
livrer à une généalogie de la pensée et
l généalogie de la morale qui sous tend
cette pensée la généalogie de la morale
c'est essayer de comprendre l'histoire
et l'origine de la morale de savoir
comment elle est née comment elle est
apparue et qui a créé la morale et à
partir du moment où on saura qui a créé
la morale on saura ce qu'est la morale
et on saura ce que vaut la morale pour
nietzsche la morale au sens où on
l'entend couramment elle est issue
d'abord de la pensée de platon fui de la
pensée chrétienne
d'ailleurs pour nietzsche il ya une
continuité directe entre le platonisme
et le christianisme
alors c'est une c'est un lien qui
pourrait en surprendre plus d'un puisque
platon c'est le 5e siècle avant
jésus-christ à l'époque de platon la
grèce et polythéistes donc dire que
platon a pu être un une espèce de
d'aspirateurs du christianisme ça peut
passer comme étant quelque chose d'assez
farfelu alors pas du tout en fait c'est
une idée très cohérente puisque le
platonisme était basé sur un dualisme le
dualisme c'est l'idée qu'il existe une
réalité qui est la nôtre
une réalité qui nous dépasse une réalité
supérieure la réalité dans laquelle on
vit c'est la réalité sensible
on a pu en parler avec schopenhauer la
réalité au dessus du monde sensible pour
platon c'est la réalité intelligible
pour platon au dessus du monde matériel
du monde physique du monde dans lequel
on vit
il existe un monde alors évidemment le
mot de monde est trompeur puisque on a
tendance à imaginer un monde matériel
justement alors que non pour platon il
existe un monde intelligible
autrement dit un monde constitué
seulement 10 des avec un i majuscule
car pour
ton toutes les choses matérielles toutes
les choses sensibles ne sont que des des
exemples des images d'objets qu'ils
appellent les idées et les idées pour
platon sont la vraie réalité c'est une
réalité transcendante de la même façon
dans le christianisme et bien il ya une
séparation à cnet qui est fait entre eux
l'ici bas et l'au delà
l'ici bas c'est l'autre monde c'est le
monde de la matière c'est le monde de la
chair donc c'est aussi le monde du du
vice c'est un nom dont il faut se méfier
c'est le monde sur lequel règne satan le
mètre d'ici bas et au contraire l'au
delà et bien c'est le paradis c'est un
monde qui n'est plus soumis aux
contraintes de la matière qui n'est plus
soumis aux vices de la chaire est pour
les chrétiens c'est ce monde là vers
lequel nous devons tendre
donc on observe un allié un
philosophique entre le platonisme et le
christianisme puisque ces deux
conceptions du monde ces deux paradigmes
repose sur une séparation entre deux
mondes un monde matériel et un monde
transcendons et cette pensée
cette pensée dualiste nietzsche
considère qu'elle est la source de la
maladie de notre civilisation
il pense que c'est cette vision du monde
qui va conduire l'homme à sa perte
c'est ce qu'il appelle le nihilisme
alors le nihilisme ça signifie le latin
il veut dire rien le nihilisme c'est la
pensée du néant et pour nietzsche la
transcendance c'est à dire le fait de ne
pas se satisfaire de la réalité
matérielle la refuser de la rejeter
voire de la condamnée en la considérant
comme corruptrice par exemple bien ça
séduit nihilisme puisque c'est une
pensée qui va chercher un ailleurs et
qui va donc rejeté la réalité dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons rechercher
un ailleurs ça signifie qu'on ne se
satisfait pas du monde dans lequel on
est et bien c'est d'ailleurs pour nous
c'est une illusion
c'est quelque chose qui n'a pas
d'existence puisque pour lui il n'y a
pas d'eau de la la philosophie de
nietzsche sur le repose sur ce qu'on
appelle le l'immanence immanence et ce
qui s'oppose à la transcendance émane
ans ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas
extérieur par rapport à la réalité et ce
mode de pensée dualiste qui comme un don
qu platonicien et aux chrétiens
nietzsche l'appelle le nihilisme le
nihilisme à penser du néant
alors la question qui se pose c'est mais
qu'est ce que reproche exactement
nietzsche à cette pensée à cette pensée
dualiste à cette pensée platonicienne à
cette pensée chrétienne
pourquoi dit il que c'est une pensée qui
va conduire l'humanité à sa perte
bien c'est assez simple à comprendre en
fait pour nietzsche toute pensée qui
repose sur une séparation entre le bien
et le mal le vrai et le faux
toutes ces séparations partir desquels
nous construisons notre pensée et notre
action toutes ces distinctions d'ordre
intellectuel et moral ont été créées de
toutes pièces
inventé par les faibles pour vaincre
l'effort pour fait pour nietzsche tous
les concepts que nous utilisons qui
repose sur une opposition qui repose sur
un dualisme il exprime ce qu'il appelle
la morale du ressentiment la morale du
ressentiment
et bien c'est par exemple la morale qui
dit que le fort n'a pas le droit
d'utiliser sa force contre le faible
c'est la morale qui dit qu'il est mal de
se comporter de manière égoïste c'est la
morale qui va s'appuyer sur la
culpabilité qui va dénoncer le vice et
le péché
autrement dit la morale du ressentiment
c'est la morale qui va nier la vie
pourquoi nier la vie parce que pour
nietzsche la vie elle est
essentiellement volonté de puissance
là encore je dois faire une précision
puisque la volonté de puissance
ce n'est pas comme on l'entend souvent
le désir de domination la recherche de
la gloire et du pouvoir non ce n'est pas
ça la volonté de puissance c'est la
puissance qui anime le monde c'est la
volonté qui anime le monde
la volonté de puissance c'est la volonté
de la puissance elle même c'est la
volonté qui affirme sa puissance dans la
réalité qui affirme sa puissance dans la
vie qui affirme sa puissance dans
l'homme lorsqu'un homme recherche la
puissance en fait il ne recherche pas la
puissance de manière indépendante et
séparée du monde c'est la vie elle-même
qui exprime sa puissance à travers cet
homme la recherche de la puissance n'est
pas quelque chose de négatif pour
nietzsche
c'est au contraire la volonté affirmatif
du monde dans sa plénitude
pour nous la puissance c'est un concept
qui a une connotation négative puisque
on associe la domination d'autrui et
pour nietzsche la puissance n'a
absolument rien à voir avec ça puisque
le fort celui qui est animé de cette
volonté de puissance guerre il n'en a
rien à faire de dominer le faible
puisque vouloir dominer le faible ce
serait déjà considéré que le faible à
une valeur ce serait lui accorder une
importance qu'en tant que faible il ne
mérite même pas donc la volonté de
puissance chez nietzsche
et effectivement un égoïsme mais c'est
un égoïsme radical c'est un égoïsme qui
ne se pose même pas la question de la
valeur d'autrui puisque l'égoïsme plein
et entier ne cherche pas à tirer profit
d'autrui il nie tout simplement autrui
il ne le reconnaît pas comme étant
autrui il ne le reconnaît pas comme
existants
la puissance chez nietzsche est un
concept absolument centrale puisque
c'est le concept selon lui qui définit
le mieux l'essence même de l'être
l'essence même de la vie l'essence même
de la réalité
on a vu avec schopenhauer que la volonté
cette es7 cette force qui s'exprimait à
travers l'espèce et à travers les
individus notamment à travers l'instinct
de reproduction
à travers le désir sexuel comme désir
inconscient de perpétuer l'espèce vous
rappeler c'est le stratagème de la
nature pour arriver à ses fins la
perpétuation dans le temps de la même
façon chez nietzsche
la vie est un mouvement qui recherchent
sans cesse à croître à s'affirmer de
plus en plus et si ce mouvement
rencontre des oppositions et bien tant
pis pour elle mais la puissance ne
s'occupe pas de savoir si elles
rencontrent ces oppositions elle broie
les oppositions sans même se poser la
question la volonté de puissance
c'est l'idée d'une force primitive
instinctive originel qui traverse tout
ce qui y est et pour niche c'est ça la
seule réalité la volonté c'est cette
force d'affirmation et de croissance de
chaque chose de chaque être
prenons un petit exemple un enfant qui
grandit il viendrait à l'idée de
personne de dire qu'un enfant qui
grandit c'est un enfant qui a envie de
prendre plus de place que les autres qui
a envie de consolider son espace vital
pour filer là la comparaison fait tout à
leur nombre l'enfant qui grandit c'est
l'enfant qui exprime et qui extériorise
le mouvement même de la vie puisque la
vie est faite pour croître et l'enfant
qui grandit il exprime cette puissance
de croissance qui est incluse dans la
vie la volonté de puissance est
l'essence même de la vie
c'est l'essence même de la réalité est
là de vie
de la volonté de puissance pourrait être
croître ou dépérir grandir ou mourir
donc pour finir sur cet aspect pour
nietzsche seule la volonté de puissance
peut être considérés comme étant dignes
de valeur et toutes les valeurs qui
repose sur le dualisme qui sont des des
inventions des faibles pour combattre
les fort bien toutes ces valeurs là pour
nietzsche n'ont strictement aucune
valeur c'est pour ça qu'on peut dire que
la philosophie de nietzsche est une
philosophie de la réévaluation puisque
pour nietzsche toutes les valeurs
existantes doivent être dévalué et
remplacées par de nouvelles valeurs des
valeurs qui vont favoriser l'émergence
de ce qu'il appelle le surhomme
le surhomme c'est celui qui ne se trouve
plus dans cette morale du ressentiment
c'est celui qui s'est affranchi de tout
les dualismes c'est celui qui accepte
l'immanence de l'être c'est celui qui
accepte le fait que la réalité que nous
connaissons
soit la seule réalité existante et cette
réalité là nous devons l'assumer
nous ne devons pas la fuir nous ne
devons pas en chercher une qui serait
meilleur puisque je recherchais une
réalité qui serait meilleur
ce serait tout simplement démontrer
notre incapacité à nous adapter à cette
réalité
ce serait donc démontrer notre faiblesse
toutes les pensées dualiste repose sur
un ressentiment
ce ressentiment il est issu de la peur
est la peur nourrit la haine nourrie la
vengeance nourrit la culpabilité et ce
sont toutes ces valeurs que nietzsche
estime être à l'oeuvre dans la morale
dominante qui est la morale chrétienne
la volonté de puissance ce n'est donc
pas un concept moral ce n'est pas une
apologie du désir de domination
pour nietzsche la volonté puissance est
l'essence même de l'être puisque la
réalité toujours en devenir
elle est toujours en mouvement le
mouvement c'est le propre de la vie
c'est même le propre de tout ce qui est
et ce mouvement c'est un mouvement vers
l'accroissement
revenons très rapidement sur la
distinction entre entre les deux types
de morale la morale des faibles et la
morale d'efforts la morale des fables on
l'a dit est basé sur une opposition des
concepts le bien et le mal
d'où vont être ensuite été habilité le
péché et levis nietzsche appelle cela
une morale du ressentiment puisque c'est
une morale qui s'occupe des autres et
cette morale qui s'occupe des autres
elle indique qu'elle ne s'occupe plus
d'elle-même elle indique donc une perte
de puissance une perte de vitalité
d'où d'ailleurs le désir de vengeance le
désir de condamner l'effort pour nos
propres faiblesses
pour nietzsche la morale du ressentiment
c'est la haine de la vie c'est
l'expression philosophique et morale de
la haine de la vie au contraire la
morale d'efforts c'est une morale d'auto
affirmation lefort n'accorde aucune
importance au faible puisqu'il ne leur
connaît même pas le force contente
d'être dans la vie se contente d'être
dans la force du devenir et si le faible
se dresse sur son passage il en subira
les conséquences de manière purement
mécanique c'est à dire que le fort ne va
pas recherché volontairement à asservir
ou a dominé le faible le faible va pâtir
de la force du fort puisque la force du
forts s'expriment points et elle ne peut
que s'exprimer puisque c'est son essence
même sur cette idée de volonté de
puissance
on peut évidemment faire un parallèle
avec la théorie freudienne du désir
sexuel puisque pour freud de toute
création est une une spiritualisation de
la pulsion sexuelle
ça signifie que à l'origine de toute
oeuvre
et bien il y à une pulsion sexuelle qui
est détourné de sa destination primaire
l'acte reproductif pour être investi
dans la réalisation de quelque chose de
supérieur
cette pulsion sexuelle bien c'est un peu
l'équivalent de la volonté de puissance
de niche dans son sens le plus
physiologique
donc je pense que vous l'avez compris
pour nietzsche les concepts
philosophiques majeurs que sont la
vérité que sont le bien et le mal bien
il ne leur accorde en fait aucune valeur
aucune espèce d'importance puisque pour
lui le problème n'est pas là
le problème n'est pas dans le concept
mais il est dans la force qui investit
le concept il est dans la puissance par
laquelle le concept sa fille le concept
n'est qu'une forme
le concept n'est qu'une coquille dans
laquelle on peut mettre tout et
n'importe quoi mais pour nietzsche
le concept n'a pas de valeur en lui-même
il n'a de valeur que par la puissance et
la vitalité dont il est chargé
et si un concept s'exprime avec une
puissance et une vitalité intense et
bien à ce moment-là il est digne de
valeur mais tout le reste n'est que
vanité
alors pour mettre en évidence le le
mépris le dédain cave et nietzsche pour
le concept de vérité pour tout ce qui
relevait en fait de la pensée
intellectuelle puisque pour lui la paix
late ce n'est rien d'autre qu'un moyen
d'adaptation de l'espèce humaine et à
moyens d'adaptation dans lequel elle a
fait pouvoir trouver un indice de sa
supériorité
or pour nietzsche latélec tu
l'intelligence ne sont pas du tout des
marqueurs de supériorité ce sont
simplement des singularités contingentes
ce sont des des propriétés que nous
avons mais qui ne valent pas
spécialement plus se sont simplement nos
outils en tant qu'humain d'adaptation au
monde qui nous entoure
rien de plus donc je disais pour mettre
en évidence ce mépris je vais vous lire
un petit texte qui est issu de la
première page d'un tout petit livre qui
s'appelle vérité mensonge au sens extra
moral dans lequel nitcheu revient sur le
concept de vérité pour montrer son
caractère factice et j'oserais dire
frauduleux il barre du long d'une image
que j'aimerais partager avec vous voici
ce qui
écrit il y eut une fois dans un recoin
éloigné de l'univers répandu en
d'innombrables système solaire
scintillant un astre sur lequel des
animaux intelligents inventaire la
connaissance ce fut la plus orgueilleuse
et la plus mensongère minutes de
l'histoire universelle une seule minute
en effet
la nature espira encore un peu et puis
l'astre se figea dans la glace les
animaux intelligents dur mourir une
fable de ce genre quelqu'un pourra
l'inventer mais cette illustration
resterait bien au dessous du fantôme
misérable éphémère insensé est fortuit
que constitue intellect humains au sein
de la nature des éternités durant il n'a
pas existé
et lorsque sens aura fini de lui il ne
sera rien passé de plus car ce fameux
intellect ne remplit aucune mission
au-delà de lui-même vie il n'est cumin
et seul son possesseur et producteur le
considère avec pathos
comme si il renfermait le pivot du monde
or si nous pouvions comprendre la mouche
nous sourions qu'elle aussi nage à
travers l'air avec ce pathos hersant
soit le centre volant de ce monde il n'y
a rien de si abjecte et de si minuscules
dans la nature qu'une légère bouffée de
cette force du connaître ne puisse
aussitôt gonflé comme une autre et de
même que tout portefaix aspire à son
admirateur de même l'homme le plus fier
le philosophe croit-il avoir de tous
côtés les yeux de l'univers braqué comme
des télescopes sur son action et sa
pensée je vais vous lire maintenant
un deuxième court extrait qui prolonge
celui là l'intellect en tant que moyen
de conservation de l'individu déploie
ses principales forces dans le
travestissement car c'est le moyen par
lequel se maintiennent les individus
plus faible moins robustes qui ne
peuvent pas se permettre de lutter pour
l'existence à coups de corne ou avec la
mâchoire a filé des bêtes de proie c'est
chez l'homme que cet art du
travestissement atteint son sommet
illusion flagornerie mensonges et
tromperies commérages parade éclat
d'emprunt masque convention hypocrite
comédie donner aux autres et à soi-même
bref le sempiternel voltige mans autour
de cette flamme unique la vanité
pour nietzsche la philosophie doit être
une exaltation de la vie un champ de la
vie
une danse de la vie alors dans son
[Musique]
oui